one piece just introduced a brand new
overpowered villain group The Holy Night
or God's night they are an elite group
of Warriors who are dispatched only when
the celestial dragons have to take care
of their most serious issues including
infighting within the world government
revolutionary Commander Dragon says that
the real fight begins only after God's
Knights are mobilized so it's clear that
these guys are the real deal since the
Admirals no longer seem as impressive as
they once were it's likely that God's
night will be the ultimate force that
the celestial dragons assemble in their
attempt to stop the revolution everyone
is speculating who these Knights are and
the only hint that we have so far is a
silhouette from chapter 1083 in this
silhouette we see 9 or 10 people
including one who looks a lot like
Shanks is Shanks a secret agent for the
celestial dragons subscribe to anime
outpro right now and you'll find out as
soon as we find out